And, uh... now it's time
to play Is This News?
Is This News?
There's this form of attention
policing on social media
where people get upset about
a news site publishing a story
they don't find newsworthy,
and they handle their outrage
in the most
productive way possible:
by whimpering,
bewildered, into the void,
"How or why is this news?"
So I'm gonna show you a tweet of
someone crying out in the dark
about a story they have deemed
unfit for publication,
and for 250 points I want you
to explain to them
why it is in fact newsworthy.
First up,
"A water main break
is the lead story on the news.
One person is without water."
@AmericasBarbie asks,
"Why is this news?"
-Ron Funches.
-Uh, because it was Ariel
from The Little Mermaid.
Oh! Yeah, that's
really important.
That's really important.
Jordan.
Uh, because that person is Jesus
and he has a wine tasting
this afternoon.
Yes, points.
Wait a minute...
Oh, I'm a little...
I'm sorry, I didn't...
You have to bring your own wine
to the wine tasting?
-Yeah. -Okay.
He's a giver, all right?
He doesn't want to take.
Hey, guys, I brought
my own wine. Oh, Jesus,
-you're the best.
-I am.
Oh, great.
Next up,
"Jeremy Corbyn
won't name his cat
and instead
simply calls it 'the cat'."
@SuneiaO_o says,
"Why is this news?" Ron.
Uh, because that's a dog, Chris.
Points.
Mike Yard.
Uh, because he named his son Son
and his daughter Lady Son.
Yeah, points.
Points.
Easy to remember.
Next up, "Kylie Jenner is down
to get hit in the face
with a hot dog."
-@emmaenders asks,
"Why is this news? -(man whoops)
Don't "woo" that.
I know why you're "woo"ing that,
and that's not okay.
I brought a hot dog...
Put the hot dog away!
Ron.
Why is this news?
It... Because it means
she reads my letters, Chris.
Yes, points.
Points.
Aah!
Jordan.
Uh, because she has to find
something to do
that her sisters
haven't already done.
Yeah, points.
Points.
Next, you guys,
uh, there's a cat
who looks like Adam Driver
that got adopted. Uh...
-YARD: That's so weird.
-Yeah, dude.
That's so crazy.
Wow.
That's amazing.
I... I don't even know why we
have to answer why this is news.
That's (bleep)...
YARD:
It's totally news.
Why is this news, Ron Funches?
Uh, because that cat
killed Han Solo.
All right, points.
Points.
Finally, Mexican
drug lord El Chapo
had 'testicle implant
for erectile dysfunction'
while on the run.
@ogoeric asks,
while laughing and crying,
"this is news because?"
Jordan.
Well, because I thought
I was donating my testicle
to a ball-less orphan.
Uh...
It hurts so much to see it
in front of me like that.
Uh, points. Mike.
Because Mexican doctors
are so skilled
that they can perform surgery
while the patient
-is still running.
-Yeah, points.